but this was actually a big mistake and
from nowhere abasov with the black
pieces could have turned the position on
its head and he could have actually
grasped a winning position with black
here Tanya
um abasov didn't find the move but he
could have played Queen to F1 and that
is certainly a boom it might not look
killing
originally but there is a major threat
of the black Rook coming in on that
second Rank and just tell us what
happened there because there was this
one big opportunity that black had and
it was right at this moment I think you
can see the board after Queen H2 uh
Queen F1 is this something uh that you
saw after playing Queen H2 what happened
here
I didn't see the moon at all
so
it just
um yeah I just escaped my um my my
vision
I mean now that I am
see it I can understand why it's
very strong but
all his ideas were sort of I thought
connected with uh
um having the queen keep attacking my
Rook on H5 so the the queen moving away
from that attack uh simply
um yeah simply Escape my my vision so
there was no moment of horror no moment
of panic just moments of ignorance
being a chess player losing even after
all these years it hurts it still means
a sleepless night I think it does for
everyone in the chat chest hurts and
that's the bottom line uh so it's and
that's it and right now it hurts the
most for obasan it's handshakes the game
is over there was nothing to be done the
last check was given which was blocked
black can't move the Rook away Queen B8
ends in Checkmate and with Nowhere to
Run for the king know where to hide it
is game over and we see them analyzing
yeah